you go up and you punch Dwayne The Rock
Johnson in the face he's stronger than
you
yeah yeah does anyone feel bad for you
when you get hit back nope why does
nobody feels bad for him why is it that
if a weaker woman hits a stronger man
and she gets hit I guess that again so
if a woman hits a man no don't worry
your argument was strength so you said
you said women women are not as strong
as men but I'm saying so if he goes up
to Dwayne The Rock Johnson Big Jack dude
yes and hits Dwayne first yeah nobody is
going to feel bad for him when he gets
knocked the [__] out because you
shouldn't have messed with him why do
women feel like it's acceptable